well hello boys and girls ladies and
germs this is tim ferriss welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
top of the day to you
my guest today is chip wilson you can
find him on twitter at
chip yvr we'll explain what that means
and online at chipwilson.com he is a
serial entrepreneur and
philanthropist there are a couple of
names you may recognize in this bio
his career in the apparel industry began
in 1979 as founder and ceo of west beach
snowboarding limited in 1998 after
selling west beach in 1997
he founded lululemon athletica inc
creating an entirely new category of
technical apparel
called athleisure which is now a 400
billion
or so global industry through his
holding company and family office
chip focuses his interests on apparel
real estate private equity passive
investments in philanthropy
chip and his wife shannon's passion for
design led to the creation of the
internationally recognized kpu
wilson school of design in 2018. in 2019
the wilson's partnered with anta sports
to buy aimer sports
which includes brands such as archeryx
salomon
and wilson sporting goods chip currently
sits
on amers board of directors the 2021
edition of his business memoir
the story of lululemon is available for
free at chipwilson.com forward slash
book so be sure to check that out
chipwilson.com
book last but not least chip is
steadfast in his pursuit to
cure fascist scapulohumeral muscular
dystrophy
known as fshd he is on the board of
fasciotherapies
that's facio and has begun his latest
big 2021 project cure fshd
as i mentioned you can find him online
chip wilson.com twitter at
chip yvr facebook chip yvr
instagram chip wilson official and
we cover a lot of ground in this one a
lot of different angles a lot of
different facets and a lot of really
good stories
please enjoy this conversation with chip
wilson
this episode is brought to you by four
sigmatic which
is part of my morning routine also part
of my afternoon
routine routine saves me so there are
a number of ways that i use for sigmatic
in the mornings
i regularly start with their mushroom
coffee instead of regular coffee
and it doesn't taste like mushroom let
me explain this first of all
zero sugar zero calories half the
caffeine of regular coffee
it's easy on my stomach tastes amazing
and all you have to do
is add hot water i use travel packets
i've been to probably a dozen countries
with various products from four sigmatic
and their mushroom coffee is top of the
list
that's number one i travel with it i
recommend it i give it to my employees
i give it to house guests so if you're
one of the 60 percent of americans or
more who drink coffee daily
consider switching it up this stuff is
amazing that's part one
that is the cognitive enhancement side
easy on the system side
energizing side the next is
actually their chaga tea which tastes
delicious
it is decaf completely decaf
and some may recognize chaga it is
nicknamed the king of the mushrooms
it is excellent for immune system
support
so needless to say i am focused on that
right now
myself and so i will often have that in
the afternoons they make all sorts of
different mushroom blends
if you are doing exercise as i am on a
daily basis to keep myself sane
cordyceps excellent for endurance they
have a whole slew of options that you
can check out
every single batch is third party lab
tested for heavy metals allergens all
the bad stuff
to make sure that what gets into your
hands is what you want to put in your
mouth and they always offer a 100
percent money back guarantee
so you can try risk-free why not i've
worked out an exclusive offer with four
sigmatic on their best-selling lion's
mane coffee i literally have a mug full
of it in front of me right now
and this is just for you my dear podcast
listeners receive up to 39
off i don't know how we arrived at 39
but 39
off it's a lot they're best selling
lion's mane coffee bundles to claim this
deal you must go to 4sigmatic.com
tim this offer is only for you and is
not available on their regular website
go to four sigmatic that's f o u r s
i g t s-i-g-m-a-t-i-c dot com
tim to get yourself some awesome and
delicious mushroom
coffee full discount is applied at
checkout
this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years i've come to conclude it
is the end-all be-all
that all good things good mood good
performance good everything
seem to stem from good sleep so i've
tried a lot to optimize and i've tried
pills and potions all sorts of different
mattresses
you name it and for the last few years
i've been sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
and like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helixsleep.com
tim take their two minutes sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty
and you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free
they'll even pick it up from you if you
don't love it and now my dear listeners
helix is offering up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com tim
these are not cheap pillows either so
getting two for free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off and two free pillows at
com slash helixsleep.com that's helix h
e
l i x sleep dot com slash tim for up to
two hundred dollars off
so check it out one more time helix h e
l i x sleep.com tim
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
chip welcome to the show thanks for
joining me well thanks tim i
hope my smile is coming through it is it
is
and i'm excited to have this
conversation for so many reasons
number one you mentioned before we
started recording you had a theory about
being 43 which is my exact age so we may
start there but also because
as you said in your words you said i'm
an open book
and i wanted to share a little backstory
so when we are
looking at different podcast guests
possible guests
we have a whole process for looking at
different types of interviews
audio video doing a whole vetting
process
asking all these questions and i got two
responses back from two different people
on my team and one was
oh my god i don't know he says exactly
what's on his mind look at all these
things
might be a red flag and then the other
person basically came back saying he
says all these things
absolute green light and i was like okay
that's perfect and as i also mentioned
before we started
i can prepare until the cows come home
but i need somebody who's who's willing
to play ball so i've been looking
forward to this
certainly know at least one of the
brands that you're
certain that you're very well acquainted
with lululemon
i wanted to start with a couple of
questions one will
will seem kind of odd but i recognize
in your social media handles
chip yvr chip yvr on twitter
facebook and so on for people who don't
know why vr
i happen to but what is yvr well that's
the airport code for vancouver yvr
and how long has vancouver been your
home stomping grounds
yeah i moved from california when i was
five to calgary
and then moved out of there when i was
16 to go to university in edmonton and
then
left there to work in alaska for two
years on the oil pipeline
came back to calgary got a job moved to
toronto for a year and then i moved to
vancouver and when the world expo was
here in 1986.
thank you for adding a few
signposts for me that we're going to
touch on because i i'm not going to
leave alaska alone but before we get to
alaska
i certainly want to explore that chapter
could you
speak to a bit of your upbringing i'd
love to
hear perhaps of your primary influences
i know you've mentioned your father
before
at least in in some interviews which i'd
be curious to hear about
but what did your upbringing look like
i'd say it was near perfect
yes my parents got divorced but they
both remarried people that were perfect
for them
i was raised in the suburbs of calgary
my dad was a phys ed teacher and my mom
was a
home sewer and you know she loved the
house and you know anything to do with
decorating with that but the sewing
machine was her love
i think i was eight years old and my dad
was running the kiwanis camp for
underprivileged kids outside of calgary
and this woman saw me swim and said you
know she'd get this kid into competitive
swimming
and so the speedo cost seven dollars
and there was no such thing as goggles
at the time so it fit into our budget
perfectly
and i started swimming you know i think
i had the perfect
i don't even have near the perfect body
as some of the people you've interviewed
before on this program
for so many me neither but good enough
and
and i believe it added incredible
structure to my life
around getting up in the morning early
swim practice i'd
train with my dad who i went to a school
when i was in grade 7 or something like
that and then training in at night
weights the whole works and had olympic
coaches and i think i more than anything
i learned about hard work equals results
and i think i learned that goal setting
really works
so when i think about other influences
of my life
i think just that middle class not
having anything
being creative learning how to go
door-to-door and selling
to raise money for the swim trips i had
to go on
you know just good prairie people i
can't say enough of that especially as i
built
you know a global business just hiring
people from their prairies
right through the u.s up to canada's
beautiful people
anyway i think i can leave it there
let's hop to alaska how did you end up
in alaska what chain of events or
decisions led you to alaska
isn't it fascinating kind of go back a
bit and just say that
at dinner parties i say i started off
and i say you make 10 great decisions in
your life
and then i asked people for their top
three
and so there i was in the edmonton
airport small little thing
and a woman comes up to me and says oh
you know my son
and i went oh yes i know your son mrs
mccarthy and we'd start talking and she
says well my husband is going up he's
running one of the five sections of the
alaska oil pipeline
which at the time was the largest free
enterprise project in the world
and massive so from valdez to prudow
obey
and i said too bad you're not american
you can come up and work with us and i
went well it just so happens i'm
american so she says
great so you know so one thing leads to
another and
i know if i get up there i can get a job
it was just a couple years after the
vietnam war
and i think i didn't you know i was like
17 years old or something like that and
and so i went up there and i went i got
to customs and i went and
said what are you doing here i said i'm
just tourist and i'm coming in as a
canadian
and he looked through my bags it was all
construction clothing etc he says well
you're coming in here to take an
america's job i can't let you in
and i said oh god it says okay i'm
coming in as an american then he says
okay step across
i stepped across he says report to your
draft board first thing tomorrow morning
and you know it was a great fear because
you'd heard so much about the vietnam
war and i still didn't really understand
you know
what would the repercussions and would
war start again would i be in that
that that was my entry into alaska and
what were you doing
as your job i was i would say the
highest paid
18 year old laborer in the whole world
it was a cost plus
job i was working getting paid 18 hours
a day probably working 10
travel time over time the whole works
and i think i made more in my first
three days because it was a u.s
holiday then i made my whole summer
working in calgary working in the parks
so i did everything from help build uh
the largest pipeline suspension bridge
in the world
to putting holes in the ground in order
to put in vertical structural members to
build a bridge and then put the pipe
across
and then i worked on we sent this
go-kart into the pipe with a couple of
welders in it my job was to put a fan on
the end and make sure it didn't run out
of gas
so and that would have been like four or
five hours with nothing to do
and i think maybe that's leading to the
biggest change in my life and
something that i know you love and my
mother
had sent me an article from a guy art
bushwald is that the right pronunciation
it was a long time ago maybe
too old for you oh good question i don't
know who that is new york times
anyway it was you have to train your
brain the same way you train your body
and then i was an athlete i understood
how to train my body and the results of
that but it never occurred to me at
training my brain that way
i decided to figure out what the top 100
books of all time was and i was going to
read them and
and so there i was probably 18 years old
and i just probably one of the best read
18 year olds in the world
all right we're gonna absolutely come
back to books but before i get
lost in my own train of thought or
the train that careens off the tracks
the theory about 43
selfishly i must ask this before we move
on i am going to come back after that
to the 10 great decisions and some of
your other
great decisions but what is your theory
about 43
well what i noticed after watching
thousands and thousands of people
is that people get glasses at 43.
have you ever noticed that like i did
glasses physical glasses
physical glasses and i was going you
know and i think there was
i also noticed there's a incredible
correlation of people getting divorced
at 43.
and i started to look at what was going
on and i thought i think you get glasses
and i think for the first time in your
life
it occurs to people that they're going
to die
and i think they start thinking about
what happens on my deathbed and
a lot of things that i think matter
don't matter and a lot of things i'm
doing
if i do this for the rest of my life i'm
going to die a miserable death
and i think people really start looking
at the person they're married to
the children they have the city they
live in the job they have
and of course this is what occurs in
men's midlife crisis
but i think the same thing happens to
women men probably go out and buy that
red convertible or they did at one point
i think they probably found something
else now
but but you get you get the idea it's a
come to jesus moment
about what life really is
yeah and i think the kids what happens
at 43 i think the children are
13 years old because i'd say most people
get married at 30
and suddenly the children don't really
want to be around the parents anymore
and don't need the parents
and the parents don't really know what
to do with themselves especially if the
couple is living vicariously through
their children
now you're 43 and you might be having
children right now and
my assistant just had his 42 just had a
child like things are changing
drastically about how long people are
waiting to have children so
that age may change yeah i'm uh i'm
happy to say that i have a zero percent
risk of getting divorced this year
because i'm not married
so i'm thrilled i'm thrilled that i've
at least for the time being dodged that
one
but i do think there i mean certainly
for me this year has been
an eye-opener with respect to visiting
thinking about mortality because i've
looked at the
average life span through my
lineage on my maternal and paternal
lines and the men
tend to croak around 85 doesn't really
matter what they do they tend to croak
around 85 and so that would make me just
past
the halfway mark which is very different
from being before the halfway mark in
terms of
orientation so uh certainly
mortality is on the mind what's your
goal what's your goal to live how long
would you like to live
you know i don't have a number in mind i
have kind of techno optimist crypto
anarchist
life extension friends who are planning
on 150
175 these types of dreams are not
new one could argue that there are
technologies
ways to deconstruct the aging process
treat it as a disease
incorporate and infuse technology kind
of brain computer interfaces et cetera
et cetera et cetera but
if i can survive ideally thrive to the
point with a high degree of cognitive
and physical functioning to the point
where i can still play sports with my
kids when they have left the home which
is at this age already
you know asking me to really keep up a
good regimen i feel like i'll be quite
happy with that
so i don't have an exact number but
having that
vision in my mind like whether we live
not to make this a soliloquy from me on
aging what do i know but i lost
my hair early which i guess was a
blessing in disguise
since i shaved my head with wrestling
but
so i've had to face some of these fears
already i spent
a good amount of time thinking about
organisms
such as trees or shifts
that take very long periods of time so
whether i live
85 75 95 125 it's all kind of the blink
of a firefly
relative to so many other things so i
don't have i don't have an exact number
do you first off i i wonder if by
just setting a longer goal first off i
wanted to live tall
80 and then i went oh well this may be
self-defeating maybe
if i think i'm going to live to 80 and
all my goals are fulfilled maybe i'll
live to 80 and then die
but if i set my goal at 120 well my
physiology and my brain
just and my the way i make decisions and
move around the world have me
live to that age and i am at 150 also
and i think everything's pointing
through peter diamandis at the
singularity university and that type of
thing if we can live 20 years longer we
can almost live forever
so technology's changing fast
it is it is i think mostly in terms of
performance
or health span i was chatting with
a friend of mine named peter tia he's an
md
uh he's been on the podcast a number of
times and he describes
something called the centenarian
olympics so it's like if you live to 100
what do you want to be able to do
at 100 right and is it sort of a goblet
squat picking up
grandkids or great-grandkids if so
where do you need to be now to look at
the incremental loss of muscle mass what
can you do to hedge that
so that when you are at 100 you were
able to do
sort of the heptathlon or decathlon of
centenarians so i do spend some time
thinking about that
so 43 check
i'm also hopefully not getting glasses
this year we'll see if i if i need to i
will
so alaska sounds like is that one of
your top three
of your top ten or it's it's one of your
top ten decisions sure it's definitely
in my top ten
to be able to go to drop everything go
somewhere where i didn't know anything
about being 17 years old
that's a big decision is more like
connected to the word suicide it's one
or the other where i'd say it's more
like
a choice i had many choices i could have
just quit university and gone traveling
go to university
gone and worked in the city been secured
a lot of what other people did i think
it looked weird to me i felt like
with what people had told me about the
money there but i didn't really believe
it that
i could trade my life in for money for a
short period of time
and then i could leapfrog my life
forward which in fact it ended up doing
and changed my context for the world you
know because it's very easy to kind of
get into a rut even when
at 17. yeah what was your
and maybe this isn't the best way to
look at it but chronologically so
let's just say we timestamp alaska
as a great decision what was your next
great choice or decision
or one that comes to mind because i'd
done so much goal setting with
swimming i didn't come to it out of
reading i think i just did it on my own
and i set these goals that by 19 i was
going to buy a house
by 30 i was going to be in my own
business
so maybe it was a choice to set goals at
that time which really then started
affecting the rest of my life
and i think to be you know sitting in i
was working for an oil company in
calgary at the age of 30
and actually quit all that security and
all that money
to start a surf brand in the middle of
the prairies in alberta
was a little bit crazy as i said
my one of my quotes is like an
entrepreneur is just is someone who's
just too incompetent to work for anyone
else
and many many people told me i wasn't
that great a corporate worker and i got
to believe them and
and in fact i just had to follow a dream
but
choices yeah so those are those are
three i think buying the house at 19
and going to my own business at 30 we're
the next couple
so starting his surf brand and leaving
the security
i want to take a closer look at because
i think
many people at some point in their lives
have an argument or a rationale along
the lines of
i'm just going to make and save money
for x number of years
and then i will do why more often than
not though
i would say that does not happen that
does not
play out according to that let's say
haphazard commitment but in your case
you wanted to have your own business by
30 you made that a goal
could you walk us through how you made
that decision what did you have a
day in the calendar you knew it year in
advance when you were going to quit i
mean how did that actually
come to manifest when i graduated at a
university when i was 25 so i was on
what i'd call the eight-year bachelor
program
[Laughter]
but i mean part and parcel of that i
have to go back and just say my
dad remarried a stewardess with air
canada and i got
five free trips anywhere in the world
and i had
in that time because you know in in
today's dollars seven hundred thousand
dollars from working the last oil
pipeline at the age of 19 i
i mean my life is it was on steroids and
i was that's a huge huge sum of money
that's a huge money it's unbelievable
and of course i
i blew a lot of it i just i used a lot
of it to educate myself for the future
what do you mean by that well i forced
mistakes i forced mistakes i
well when i traveled a lot with the
money i would take courses in university
that i thought were bizarre
you know i take public speaking and
agriculture uh
you know novels of the american mid-50s
type of thing and
i had time so i had time to learn but i
think when i got into the business of
making apparel which was really when i
was 25 as i
as at the same time i had this corporate
job my travel to brazil or
bermuda to find out about long shorts
because long shorts had never
been seen before but in bermuda all the
men wore long shorts
to going to san clemente california to
the hoffman's fabrics there and learning
about how much fabric i had to buy in
order to get
my own pattern and where to import it
from and how to do
financing for it i mean these are all
things that i forced upon myself and
it was all very expensive but i had the
money to do it with
how did you go from pipeline to
apparel or when did that
interest slash direction develop
it was probably always there i mean my
dad is a phys ed teacher my mom is a
sower
and myself as an athlete especially
being in a speedo
when i started moving out of competitive
swimming and i started to do triathlons
when they first started in maybe 1980 or
something like that
the clothing was terribly made so
my actually my first my first venture
into apparel was making triathlon
clothing
and of course there was a global market
of about 200 people for it so that was a
i learned that i needed economy of scale
production to make any money and that
was one of my learnings there
what happened is i brought that
triathlon clothing
and at the same time i you know as i
said i was originally from california
and my parents would ship me back every
summer time and
probably from 1960 on so i got to see
how
apparel in california changed year by
year i mean in snapshots
i think if you're living in the forest
you can't see the trees growing if
you're outside and you come there you
can
once a year you can see it and
definitely there's this thing called
surfing which was
and surf clothing which is really coming
from australia into
california at the time i kind of put
that together with having traveled to
you know brazil and like i said bermuda
to learn about long shorts and then
putting the technology together about
what i wanted to wear as an athlete
and then what i wanted to wear when i
wasn't being an athlete
so was the the advent in the what was
i'd say 1963 or four of the hoodie
you know on the beach you know which i
think silicon valley has adopted as
their
de facto uniform yeah exactly
so um what really happened is i came
back in night when i was 25
i came back from california with a pair
of these shorts from my girlfriend they
were kind of wrap shorts
made like diapers but made out of
floured fabric she loved them all her
friends love them
because i i had contacts from my mother
about how to make a pattern and how to
sew
i just put those two things together and
said well if you like them so much and
your friends like
let's make a whole bunch so and then we
kind of went through the process of
pattern making getting sewers creating
an industry out of that
and so that's how it got to be when i
was 30 years old i could afford to quit
my corporate job and go into that
full-time
you mentioned a few goals you mentioned
buying the house
you mentioned starting your own business
did you have
goals going out 5 10 15 20 years
beyond that in other words by the time
you started that business
did you have a longer list
of goals ahead of you that you'd already
written out
i only only one more and that was to be
retired by
40. and when i mean retired that means
getting up in the morning and doing
exactly what i wanted to do
and it took me until 42 to get there so
i failed
but you know it got me there
yeah you mentioned the goal setting with
respect to
athletics i know that there are a number
of authors and books that we may end up
talking about during your period of
voracious consumption
in alaska and then beyond i know a
couple of names jim collins
brian tracy and then ayn rand alice
shrugged
and others did any particular books
influence you when it came to how you
set goals
definitely inside of the psychology of
achievement by brian tracy has about
maybe an hour hour and a half on goal
setting so i learned the
linguistic structure of goal setting i
think they were smart goals
but fundamentally i i didn't like them
i did like them what i didn't like was i
learned that
i was setting my goals from my past
so in other words i had lived a life
with
experiences and maybe the easiest one
for me to say is just you know weight
you know i was probably 242 pounds so
you know just thinking about being 242
pounds i went well i want to be
220 or something so i would set a goal a
year in the future that i wanted you
know i will be
220 pounds by december 31st
2015 something like that but what i
really got from the landmark
course which has been really fundamental
to me
is that i could see how constraining my
life was
creating my future from the past
as opposed to creating my present from
the future
it's really easy if i woke up in the
hospital with amnesia
having been in a car accident and i got
to set goals
well i wouldn't be able to set them from
my experiences in the past
so basically what i'm saying i'd be
unconstrained
and so i started to think about that
weight one and going well if i was to
wake up in the hospital with amnesia i'd
probably do a little bit of research
and then find out that the optimum
weight is 208.
so i could start to see how constraining
goals were
from this past base part
i think putting those two ideas together
changed goal setting for me
in smart goals the a is for achievable i
got to find out very
young age how failure was you know
because i pushed for failure a lot
that failure was actually a great thing
to learn and it and to accept it as a
kind of an exciting thing like a
learning experience so
i like to set my goals so i'll fail 50
of the time now i don't go out of my way
to fail
but if i fail now i get to reset my life
reset that goal and go after it again
if it's exciting to me could you give us
any examples
of goals that you are proudest of
achieving goals that you're proudest of
not achieving i don't know if that's the
best way to word it but
there's part of me and this is just
thinking out loud just going to say
speaking out loud which is uh
usually the case is if
the achievable needs to be modified
so that even if you're failing half of
the time you're not failing completely
in other words like if you set your
goals really aggressively and you
succeed partially you're probably still
quite ahead on the scoreboards when you
kind of look at
how things settle could you walk us
through any examples of
of goals you've set that you've achieved
and not achieved
i'd like to take it back into my dad as
you asked about earlier because i don't
want to let the story go to waste
and it's really a good one on goal
setting so i was 10 years old
i was a mediocre swimmer i'm at the end
of the pool
about to do the 100 meter backstroke my
dad comes up to me and said
instead of like going 80 percent and
trying to
save to the end and trying to look good
at the end by kind of sprinting or
having anything left at the end
i want to just try once to go full out
like
full out and you know if on a 25 meter
pool if you
drown on the third length i'll come and
get you type of thing and so
i can sense in my mind like there was
okay so there's a goal
now the goal is the canadian record
i'm eight seconds off the canadian
record there's no way
but in fact by going full out and giving
a hundred percent that's exactly what
happened i broke the canadian record
so my context then for goals and things
that i do
if i don't give a hundred percent i'm
afraid i'm going to fail
which is the very opposite than how most
people are how you phrase it about
always saving a little bit again even at
that young age came from i never wanted
to be on my death bed going if i didn't
give it all when i was 10 years old in
that race
would i be spending 90 years thinking
about oh i wish
i never want to be in that position so
consequently i've
i've failed a lot because i do exactly
that
but the wins that i get are far
exceed those those failures so that i
end up
it appears as though i've ended up
living the life that i wanted to live
are there any goals that you can share
that you
haven't reached that nonetheless you are
glad you set as goals
when i was at lou lemon my goal would
have been to
train and develop 100 000 people
through this transformational
development program that had set up
you know including the landmark
psychology of achievement good to create
seven habits of highly effective people
it was a program that it had set up that
way
which i probably got to 20 000 and then
i kind of lost control of the company
i felt like i could have really changed
the way corporate america
changed how to make profit how to
how to develop people i think just by
coincidence i just happened to end up in
a business with women at exactly the
right time when
when they were just so highly educated
and nobody else was really
training and developing them so i i
think i got attached to
developing women and board of directors
and everything like that but i think i
was more just in the right place at the
right time
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
layered superfood founded by one of the
kings of big wave surfing laird hamilton
and volleyball
champion gabby reese layered superfood
delivers high impact fuel to help you
get through your busiest days i just had
a bunch of their products this morning
about an hour and a half ago
i love their turmeric superfood creamer
and the unsweetened superfood creamer
both can really optimize your daily
coffee or tea ritual so i combined it
with puare tea
a 10 bag will last you a long time i
basically
use the unsweetened superfood creamer
like
powdered mct oil so if i'm doing
intermittent fasting or any number of
things
i will use that and i use it at least
i'd say four or five times a week
the creamers are packed with real
plant-based ingredients like organic
extra virgin coconut oil coconut milk
and aquaman
they come in flavors like cacao and as i
mentioned turmeric
each serving is packed with a full range
of mcts medium chain triglycerides
to help keep you going from am to pm and
i have spent time with i've stayed at
the home of
laird and gabby and they are one of the
most powerful couples
i've ever met in my life they've been on
the podcast as well so they introduced
me to these products
and i've been hooked for a limited time
layered superfood is offering you guys
off your order when you use code tim20
at checkout that's tim20
check out layeredsuperfood.com tim to
see my favorite products
and learn more once again use code tim
to get 20 off your order go to
layeredsuperfood.com
tim
i was going to jump next to this
transformational curriculum which we
will get to
but i want to add a little connective
tissue so
you have west beach
that's 1979 right you're getting it
right why didn't you continue with that
indefinitely i guess i'm wondering if
you could just share with me and with
listeners
what transpired once that found its
groove
and what led you to lululemon
this probably isn't a secret to anybody
that's that's watched
businesses rise and fall but the surf
business started off with about three or
four companies
and then very quickly went to 500
companies when everyone discovered i can
make clothing in the whole world and
wants surf clothing
so let's say that's between 1978 and
1985 and so it gets to 500 companies and
suddenly there's too much supply for too
few buyers and then there's the mergers
and acquisitions
phase the bankruptcy phase and then i'd
say
three or four of the strongest companies
end up buying all the rest of the brands
or whatever brands are left and then
that's
that's how it ends up being same in the
us auto industry and then it went global
now it's happening on a global stage so
i saw that happening and surf and just
so happened that skateboard starting and
i decided to switch the company from
surf into skateboard
and of course i had the perfect shorts
for them because i had these long shorts
so
it was the first time long shorts that
came out the kids loved them for their
knees because they kept falling on their
knees and there was no knee pads at the
time
so i guess that context of saying
oh i saw what happened that surf
industry i bet you the same thing's
going to happen in skateboarding
and sure enough skateboarding went
straight up you know from
1983 to probably you know 1987
and then started to decline and at the
same time this thing called snowboarding
happened
and so i could see now i had kind of
like this winning formula okay if
there's a time to get in and there's
time to get out of an industry
so it just so happened i'd moved from
calgary to vancouver and because of
whistler
it's got a glacier that's opened all
summer long and all the
best snowboarders from the world would
congregate in the summertime in whistler
to
practice on the glacier i saw that occur
and then went okay so now i got it in my
mind like every five years
the world of which i'm let's call it i'm
an expert in now
changes and so the idea is i got to get
in on a sport at its beginning
and then understand a sport that is not
just going to be
technical but it's also people want to
wear on the street to kind of
show that they're part of that sport
and so i failed in mountain biking and
beach volleyball that didn't work
so there's some failures for it for you
but
i had an opportunity to sell west beach
the snowboard company to
moral snowboards out of salem oregon in
when the japanese yen was at its very
highest because japan was buying 30
of all snowboard gear around the world
and
the trend was kind of moving over so it
was the right time to sell
and i sold and i had nothing to go to
and then
it was just i did something which i'd
seen in a lot of my life as i saw three
things happen in one week
and i went this is a trend i gotta get
on it and it was yoga
so i had a bad back from skateboarding
and snowboarding had fallen so many
times and
and so i picked it up and uh well no i
first off i saw a one of those rip away
tabs on a telephone post for yoga
and then i read an article in the paper
that said you know something about
yoga and then i was in a coffee shop and
i heard two women talk about yoga all in
one week and i went man this is
i gotta like look at this and so that's
that's how that ended up happening
where i did fail was actually moving
into meditation for lou lemon
you know i tried to move it there but i
mean that's another story or maybe we
can talk about it later
all right i'll take a note of meditation
lululemon there's all sorts of lore
around this name what are some of the
other
options if you remember that you
considered for the company and how did
you end up on lululemon
um i wish i could remember more of the
names now
but the only one i can remember is one
of them was athletically hip
and it's because i was a tragically hip
music fan but also because in the book
catch
22 you know there's a part in there
where
the write letters home and then the
censor would write on the bottom
tragically yours and so it's kind of
like this
combination of things yeah so
well it's a great story as i think all
good brands have
and so when i had the skateboarding
business i
bought another company called homeless
skateboards
you know i started selling it to the
japanese into the europeans and it was
all going well but
skateboarding i said i was going down
and snowboarding was going up so i made
that tough business decision to go
i'm stopping on skateboarding i'm going
to put all my efforts into snowboarding
so you know i had to know the japanese
at the time like
they really put a lot of money and
effort into the brand of homeless
they really like the style and i was
cutting this brand off at the throat so
to speak
one of the things i tried to do i tried
to trademark it but
hom is french for mail and there was too
many names like that so
that wasn't possible so i stopped
producing the brand i didn't own the
name
and later that year i'm showing the
japanese our snowboard brand and
afterwards they go oh mr chipsen
we want to where's homeless and i said i
told you guys i'm not doing it you know
and i gave him the reasons
meanwhile the japanese yen was at its
very highest i mean they were buying
pebble beach the empire state building
they were buying up america
a lot like the chinese are doing now and
so
they called me up and they went mr
chipsen we want to buy name homeless
from you
so i went okay well i'm selling pure
error here because i don't own it i'm
not making it i gave him a price i
thought was absolutely ridiculous and
they went
hmm okay and i went oh that's the
easiest money i ever made in my life
and i went why did they like that name
so much
and i started to surmise that the
young people who wanted to buy american
brand names
they were being fed by the five big
trading companies in japan
the american brand names you know that
they were that the japanese
trading companies were making but real
authentic american names had an l in it
because a japanese company wouldn't come
up with a name with an l in it
so i went oh okay so i know what i'm
going to do next time i have a name
i'm going to come up with the name for
business i'm going to put three l's in
it and see if i can get three times as
much
how did you come up with the name
lululemon
well it was purely i think i was just
working on alliterations
and it was like maybe for two or three
years it was just
i just wrote it down one day i'm amongst
these other 20 names of which i got
100 women to choose from the names and
the logos
they ended up picking the name lou lemon
and then they like the logo from
athletically hip which is just an
a with a circle around it amazing
when you sold that brand the homeless
brand do you recall the the year or the
rough
timing of that 1994
94 yeah that would have been a few years
three
a few years after i left japan i was
there as an exchange
student where i was the that's right at
one point he only
wears waldo american student in a school
uniform
in japan and it was fascinating to see
the cult devotion developed around
certain brands and they were amazing
both foreign brands
or brands that were perceived to be
foreign but were actually created on
home soil
in japan i mean there were these denim
brands that had brad pitt as a
spokesperson there was mr coffee
which had tommy lee jones still i think
uses tommy lee jones
and then separately this incredible
excitement
around actual u.s brands or european
brands
so something i got to see firsthand and
for people who are curious
i'll just mention that the question of l
and r
in japanese is an interesting one
linguistically because
japanese is a syllabary so they have
syllables instead of
independent consonants so you have like
kakiku
and then there's and so it's the
sound that they use that is most
approximate to an l
is actually a combination of r l and d
and
that's part of the reason they have such
a challenge with distinguishing those
so lululemon what were your expectations
or hopes
for lululemon in the beginning quite
honestly after working for
20 years at west beach not paying myself
30 000 a year
and then being able to sell it for a
million dollars pay 200 000
in tax and buy a house and buy a car put
my kids in that school which you know
they're appropriate for
i was sitting around and i didn't have
anything so it was in the
quest of nothing so i started lou lemon
with the goal of being able to ride my
beach cruiser to work and back every
day have one store and
make it the best in the world and i was
really really really tired of being
around people who i didn't want to work
with
and so to be with people i wanted to
work with then i knew that i
had to set up a development program in
order to
develop people to have the opportunity
to be people i wanted to be around
so my goal was ride my beach cruiser and
work with great people
and have the best quality product in the
world
and then determine whether this new idea
i had
of vertical retailing so missing the
wholesale business and of course the
analogy now is people that go direct to
e-commerce so
but at that time you know i was on the
forefront of that so
i wanted to see these three things work
and just to
for my own clarity when you say vertical
you mean rather than going through
distributors and wholesale accounts and
all of that you're creating your own
retail outlets to sell directly to
consumers
correct i mean it's not like other
people weren't doing that i mean maybe
the gap was doing it maybe a few others
but
i started in 1980 with west beach
but i was trying to run two different
businesses a wholesale
and my own retail stores where i could
design
manufacture and sell right to my own
stores so i was missing like
the manufacturer's markup and the
wholesale markup it was seemed like an
easy business to me and i didn't realize
that
actually invented something i guess
so i want to i want to give a nod before
we move any further
to a listener of this podcast named
christian
beutzek i might be getting that
pronunciation wrong but who
suggested a whole number of questions
for you
and and they uh think this is as
opportune to time as any
to present a few of them they're
actually very well thought through but
very difficult to fact check
so so you'll have to you'll have to let
me know if any of these are off i'm just
going to use
almost like sentence fragments that we
can launch off of and i'm doing this
right now for
for a reason so one of the bullets that
he put in this email
is chip pitches a tent in his store and
sleeps in it to save on theft insurance
for how many years did he sleep in his
own store can you
elaborate is this a true story it is a
true story i
i really had run out of money almost
three times
starting lou lemon and we had a store
there was starting to be a lot of
break-ins in the area i couldn't afford
the insurance on break-in insurance and
i determined that break-ins only
happened on friday and saturday night
and so i took my two sons
and that's where we spent friday and
saturday night in a tent
in the store did anyone ever try to
break in did you ever
work any invaders no
how long did you uh did you do that dude
over what period of time
i'd say about six months yep all right
so i wanted to introduce that
because then it offers a contrast
with where i want to go next which is
this number you mentioned like around 20
000 like 20 to 30 000 people who have
gone through
this transformational curriculum which
was
set up at lululemon and
i think those numbers if not all of
those people a very high percentage
would have gone through
the landmark training which is correct
which is involved
and not not inexpensive i found an
interview
where the following came up and i'd love
to hear you
elaborate on this because i'm sure a lot
of thought went into it firstly we had
five books or courses which everyone
took in the first two to three weeks
they were with the company
out of this we created a linguistic
abstraction of 30 terms and definitions
which became the culture
of our company that allowed us to expand
exponentially because suddenly everyone
was speaking the same language so this
is
all super interesting to me and
i'd love to start with the five books or
courses i think you mentioned
a number of them earlier but if you
wouldn't mind to the best of your memory
what were some of the required books and
required
trainings so to speak that people would
go through so the 3da
landmark course which in summary really
taught me about
integrity responsibility and choice
the brian tracy psychology of
achievement
which really did a study of
successful people and what successful
people do and don't do
everything from raising children to
religion to communication to
philanthropy to goal setting the whole
gambit
the third would have been and i of
course you know we both love this book
good to great
and just the context that good is the
enemy of great
this is just like it's just an amazing
context for me
the next one would have been the seven
habits of highly effective people
by um covey all these things are so
relevant today i mean maybe they're a
little bit outdated
anyway so is carnegie i guess and then
the fourth one would have been
the goal by goldblatt and it's really a
fiction book very fun to read about the
constraint theory of production
so you know he has children and he's
having a hard time getting the factory
but he gets the factory
it's it's i can't believe that someone's
taken something so boring and made it so
interesting
what was the i i'm gonna admit i don't
know what that
constraint refers to i don't know what
that is why was this important for
people to read
coming from japan i think a lot of this
came from japan
because things are in there that
big public companies can't do if you
have a
factory that's at 80 capacity and is
making a profit
and is fulfilling on what you want it to
do then
if you can fulfill on the rest of the 20
in the factory your profit margin on
that is almost
exponential so
for instance lou lemon went to move into
australia
so in order to win australia we could
actually move our production up from the
to 100 percent and then take a lower
margin in australia to win the
marketplace
because it really didn't cost us
anything more to put on a few zeros on
the production line
that's one of like 20 ideas that would
be in the book
is it a book you would recommend to
people
who operate outside of manufacturing or
is it really
a kind of specialists i'd say anybody
that's producing anything
um that's not digital because digital
works on a whole different level
got it to the goal and are there any
others you'd like to mention before i
ask some follow-ups on on landmark
i love mindset by carol duke i think you
had her you
may have you may have talked to her at
one time i we've had
i think we've had some communication uh
but that is
certainly a book that comes up as
recommended
quite a lot on the podcast i really like
black box thinking
the amazing story there of the planes
that were coming
back and landing in world war ii and
they'd have a bunch of holes in the
bottom and they'd
looked at the patterns and go yeah we'll
cover up where all the bullet holes are
where
really those are the ones that were
making it back it's where the bullet
holes weren't
is where you need to put the extra
protection in and
it's really a way of looking at
businesses which i don't think
especially boards of directors and
people who aren't really
in the business and don't really
understand the business are looking for
the holes and the planes that are
landing where probably the entrepreneur
founder someone who's looking in the
forecast can actually see
what's occurring that doesn't look
normal were these books
these recommendations landmark were they
required or just
available and recommended
no the five books the five the landmark
and the four courses were required
in other words we set up our training
and development program to
talk about these almost well quarterly
but because we had goal settings set
into place and the goal setting like i
said
creating your goals from the future and
failing 50
at a time we would have those done
monthly and really we would bring a lot
of the learnings from the other books
into the practice of goal setting how
did you
have those conversations was it broken
down
by location was it virtual
how were those conversations taking
place what we learned from the brian
tracy is to
set your the goals and then to post them
so if you went into a lou lemon store
every store had maybe 15 to 40
goals set up in the back room and so
everyone could look at everyone else's
goals
and the idea is to put it out there in
the public
in other words the landmark course
really got rid of people's
fears about what people think of them or
what they call when the linguistic
abstraction is looking good
so mostly people go around in the world
looking good trying to pretend there's
something that they're not
so by putting up the goals then and
recognizing that
we're all human beings and we all have
different things that we want to do
and there's no right or wrong on our
goals and also i
a real underlying part of it was that we
actually encouraged people to quit
lou lemon like we wanted them to have
goals that were
superior or that moved on to their
somewhere in their future that
we were training and developing these
people and they were going to go on and
do what they really wanted to do in life
and my theory was if we trained people
to be great
and they left lou lemon and went and did
something else
they would talk so well about lou lemon
in the future
that that was the best branding and
marketing we could possibly do
were those goals that were posted
publicly revisited
in some systematic way or reviewed
in such a way that people felt somewhat
accountable
yes so they were reviewed
i think quarterly and
we encourage people to not get stuck in
any goals
you know if something worked last
quarter but doesn't work anymore
dump it and get something that you're
excited about i think it's important to
say
that inside of this we had 18 goals
so first off we started from something
that would be
at that time was a vision your 10-year
vision and then you had
your values maybe three values
of which i can i've changed a lot of my
thinking around this
and then we have goals for one year five
year and ten years
so from your vision then it's easy to
set ten year goals from your ten-year
goals once those are done it becomes
easier is that five year goals
and then it becomes quite easy to set
one or two year goals
and everything has to be with um
conditions of satisfaction with a buy
when date
so as you know from brian tracy it's
fascinating how people will get around
setting goals and being specific about
it because they don't want to be
responsible
for actually fulfilling on them so
i found eighty percent of the time
people would not put a buy when date
when they were going to do it
or they would put the condition of
satisfaction so vague
that nobody knew whether it actually got
done or not
because people don't want to fail and
people want to look good in front of
other people
but once you kind of get that the whole
world is walking around trying to look
good
i found it really released our people
from looking good and
getting rid of all the shoulds and
wishes and tries in life and actually
become an
authentic human being that has issues
just like anybody else then i think it
just freed our people up to be open and
undefended about their goals
what do you think if and i know you've
already described a few but what are the
what are the strongest aspects or the
greatest strengths
of landmark and
what are any of the weaknesses
if any come to mind well the weakness is
that
people come out of it like they've seen
jesus so
you know this is where the cult part
comes in at
but i first took it when i was 35 and
i really really didn't get the life that
i was living and
basically i was always living in the
angst of something i'd done wrong in the
past
or living in the future that wasn't here
yet and i was trying to figure out what
to do to survive
i had lived my first 35 years of my life
never
really being in the present and
as my dad would said when i was 17 years
old as i rolled my eyes that the meaning
of life is living in the moment
and of course he you know as a burnt out
hippie and i you know
why should i listen to him type of thing
anyway he ended up being right
so this ability to freely choose as
though i have amnesia
to be in the present and then it was
very clear to me because after
years of athletics of swimming and
triathlons and squash
recognizing that that three hours after
an
aerobic workout my mind was so clear
and i surmised it was for the same
reason as that endorphin rush kind of
eliminated my past and i didn't care
anything in the past if you don't have a
past then you don't have a future
now what does that mean imagine it's
impossible to think about
anything in the future without relating
it to some experience in the past
so if i don't have a past then i don't
have a future
and i think this is the same reason that
people get drunk or stoned to a great
extent
because it's the act of eliminating the
past
so there's no past there's no future all
there is is the present
you know i think it's the 45 seconds
after sex i think it's uh
you know you can see a three-year-old
child crawling around the rug
they have no past they have no future
they're also
so creative and i also see it in older
people when they're told they've got
three months until they die they could
care less about their past they have no
future
and they're looking at every blade of
grass so anyway that's the come to jesus
moment that i really got
and the second part was integrity and
what i really got out of it is that
everybody thinks they have integrity but
in fact
because everyone has a different
definition of integrity there is no
integrity
so then the act of actually defining
was super important and i took the same
line that landmark does and i'm going to
bastardize it a little bit but
integrity is doing what i say i will do
when i say i will do it in the expected
way
and if i can't get it done then i have
to clean up my mess
and be responsible for that mess clean
it up
and then set new conditions to
satisfaction and new buy when dates
so the whole company of lou lemon
operated under that integrity principle
and it meant you know our meeting
started on time you did what you said
you were going to do
and it's not like if i
say that i'm going to be in a meeting on
time and i'm driving to work and
i get a telephone call saying my boy has
been run over by a car
i'm not going to make it to that meeting
it doesn't make me wrong that's not what
integrity is
there's many times when people can't be
in integrity
but to clean up the mess caused by lack
of integrity is where more integrity
occurs
so that's the other thing so the third
thing then i think is most
most interesting to me is this thing
about being responsible
i could sense that i was a complainer in
life you know i complain
complain complain but you know of course
we all know that
after two complaints nobody would listen
to me anymore it took me a while to get
that
but more interesting is that when i was
responsible
for whatever the situation was then
immediately i had the power to do
something about it
you know when i left lou lemon i could
complain about it
or i could decide to do something about
what i saw
wasn't working inside the company so
then to be responsible i got okay i'll
write the book
on how i think lou lemon should operate
and
give context to the history and to the
future so that
the existing management board of
directors can have some
template to go on so that's how i was
being responsible
are there any companies that come to
mind that you think do a
good job of talent development
or employee development and
alternatively why don't you think more
companies do
what you did with the required
curriculum
i don't think i would know about other
companies because i'm not really in them
except for the ones i'm in now
through the new purchase of ammer and
these eight brands that are inside of it
i think fundamentally more companies
don't do it because of litigation
out of the u.s i think in order to take
the landmark course because
you know people have this kind of come
to jesus moment
and they've had to put into the writing
of it before you
go into the course that you know you
have no psychological issues and blah
blah blah all the literature all the
legal literature that actually if
someone was to look at it would scare
the hell out of you there's just no way
you would do the course
could you give some more examples of the
linguistic
abstractions those terms and definitions
which i guess
are sort of shorthand for
fast communication if i'm understanding
it correctly
as i said i used to think it was values
but i found that
like the word extreme in the 80s
everyone started making fun of the
extreme and advertising started using
that
and i think that people now hear values
and the companies they start to roll
their eyes and yeah yeah everyone's got
the same values type of thing
i have been encouraging the companies
i'm working with what are the five books
that really define this company and
really light people up
and then out of those take 30 terms and
definitions
that are key to those five books and
develop a
linguistic abstraction which you can
grow a global company
on and everybody knows and understands
so
you're right it's about speed of
communication some of them have already
gone over and that would be
conditions of satisfaction and a buy
when date
the definition of integrity i have them
listed in my bathroom on the wall
so they're sitting there and you know
i've read them five
thousand times this is in your personal
bathroom
yeah well office bathroom also in our
office bathroom
yeah we have the linguistic abstraction
and then something i call the code
which is um originally at lou lemon
i think it was the best and most
incredible marketing thing anyone's ever
done
and we put this code that really came
from the landmark and
all these five books that we've talked
about and
things my dad told me and we put them on
the side of the bag the shopping bag the
blue lemon shopping bag
and it probably existed like that for
about maybe until a year after i left
but then they
the marketing department or the legal
people kind of came into it again and
went
you can't say that anymore social media
is making us in trouble
you know it'd be something like instead
of suntan lotion which probably has a
lot of chemicals in it why don't you
just get the right amount of sun
so of course the fear around suntan
companies like suing lou
lemon you know just overtakes the
company and
so those are the kind of things that so
anyway they did away with it
well i want to come back to those types
of conversations
but let me ask a maybe fundamental
question about another term
that much like integrity is either
not defined at all or defined in so many
different ways
that it might as well not be defined
brand i think
a lot of people if they were asked does
lululemon have a strong brand
they would say yes but if they were
pressed to define what that means i
think a lot of people would struggle
so what is a brand in your mind and what
is it not
it's a fascinating conversation
especially in today's social media world
about
you know as things that move further to
the left and
anything that is said can be you know
construed one way or the other
i believe that people originally set up
a brand in order to
target a certain market and the more
specific you are
about who your market is then the better
job you can do about
giving them the product that they want
and
i think if i see any failure in
american public companies over infinitum
it's eventually trying to be everything
to everybody
and of course this flies in the face of
these
terms like diversity i think it's
impossible to be
great being everything to everybody so
you know for instance clothing lines
have always been separated between
children's lines teens lines
women's lines and then maybe retired
people's lines
because bodies change tastes change
colors change and
a company that tries to be everything to
everybody
it's just too messy you end up with so
much product and you have no
what are you getting out there as is who
you are
to those people my fear is is for a
company like lou lem that's trying to be
everything to everybody is that will
they end up going the way of the gap
and he's becoming another common company
and then you know
because i think we you can become
everything to everybody and you're gonna
make a lot of profits for five years
because all those people who weren't
your customers before now start flooding
in
but what eventually happens is the the
key drivers are the key consumers are
the mavens and the connectors
who really move a brand forward start
stop
buying the brand but the board of
directors
and a ceo who's uh you know got three
year options is going to go for the
short term
profitability so there's almost no
stopping it
unless unless you have an owner operator
type ceo yeah it's uh
i suppose whether we like it or not
humans are driven by incentives
right oh my god ever
it's like if you want someone who's
incentivized
to outperform for three months over a
few successions because of their option
plan
versus an owner operator who's in it for
a hundred years
uh you're just going to get very
different behaviors well if i could say
one more thing about this really this
just came to me like a couple weeks ago
but
if you have an owner that's out there
making decisions for a hundred years and
you have a private equity
firm inside whose goal is to get in and
out in seven years
that's fundamentally a problem inside of
the company
because the pe firm wants short-term
profits they want to pump everything up
and get out and the
owner is trying to like put the money
where it'll be good for 20 years from
now
it's really fascinating yes
the study of humans also the study of
conflict alas
um i want to ask maybe not directly
about conflict but i want to come back
to
free speech social media things like
that but first
i want to ask about some really micro
details this might be getting into the
weeds but i'm very very
interested because i believe that you
consider store design
a crucial endeavor area of focus
i could be mistaken but what are some
strategies
or approaches that you used for
increasing retail sales
so the number of products in the store
change rooms mirrors color of walls
what were some of the elements that you
experimented with fundamentally i think
the first big difference
for lou lemon that was so different than
any any other
clothing brand was that we weren't run
by
merchandisers so people that were liking
sacks were trying to put
10 different brands together make all
the the purses in the shoes and
everything look
good together so rather than do that
lou lemon was his first a functional
company
and actually all my companies are i work
at the same level
so function is number one so not only is
the apparel functional but then you make
it beautiful
so the store had to be functional so
rather than have
a wall where pants and jackets and tops
you know t-shirts and accessories all
work together in one color way and we're
pretty
i'm going to use this word pretty so to
speak so that when
people went in they would go wow you
know type of thing
but the problem is is that within like
even
seven days one or two sizes would be
sold out and probably the most popular
sizes so
we did do that we'd set things up for
seven days like that but then
the store was set up to put pants would
be in one area
tanks and another shorts in another and
you would actually go
to look at a mannequin that's the short
that i want you'd be educated on why
that short was being made
you'd go down to size six there's your
colors and then you could pick that
and then you could go to a tank top or
whatever and you could look at all the
sixes and all the different styles and
go
okay i like that design of tank here's
my size six
here's the color i want and go with it
basically i was setting it up
because i wanted i understood clearly
from listening to women that they were
time constrained
and if they could get in and out of a
store in under 10 minutes with exactly
what they wanted
then i was actually saving them 100 or
because i always came from that our
customers were making a hundred dollars
an hour
coming in the store so then we set up
the right amount of change room so they
never had to wait for a change room
we did the hang tags all on the same
side we had the price that was big the
size that was big you didn't have to
search for anything
the store was set up functionally so you
could get what you wanted into the
change room
there was three-way mirrors so a girl
didn't have to come out and get
have someone asked they could actually
check their own sides out if they wanted
to do that
our cash register had the fastest
checkout for you know
by the time you scanned it and got the
price out and you're out the door
so i think women really appreciated that
well it seems also
to emerge a lot of these decisions
from having a very clear picture
of who your customer
is which you alluded to based on the
assumption or archetype that as one
factor has
the income of a hundred dollars per hour
that allows you if you
set that as your base assumption slash
target it allows you to make
many many other decisions very quickly
it would be very well said
very well said yep exactly let's
revisit the linguistic abstractions
since we just took a very gratifying
bathroom break and we're back in action
i feel so much better i've i've i'm in
the process of rehydrating
and you've printed out as the
overachiever you are
the linguistic abstractions so please
share
so being present we've talked about
clearing the past we've we haven't
really talked about but it's the same
thing
i noticed that if i was to talk to you
but you had your mind on your business
or your girlfriend
or you wanted to go skateboarding or
whatever
you really wouldn't be listening to me
and this idea that
there's no point in me talking until
i've cleared what it is that's
going on with you you may have another
meeting to go to that something's more
pressing
so i've got to make sure i clear you
the listener before i can actually
talk i've wasted a lot of time
forcing what i have to say down somebody
who's not listening
[Laughter]
we've talked about creating the present
from the future
so committed listening is another one so
on the opposite end of that
so when you're talking i've got to
consistently clear myself so that i can
actually
hear what it is that you're saying often
i find somebody starts talking
and on my mind goes i'm really
interested in this
mirror neurons and how i really get now
when i'm
talking and somebody isn't listening i
can tell that they're not listening
fascinating really so we know on a
subconscious level
that somebody isn't listening looking
good we've talked about
winning formulas is an interesting one
so
winning formulas winning formula so when
i was
12 my parents were divorced
um i was a competitive summer i came
home for lunch and nobody was there and
there was no food
so i forged my mom's check went down to
safeway bought some food
and my 12 year old self told me that i
couldn't
trust even those who love me to take
care of me
and so i then have to
if it's to be it's up to me and i can't
depend on anyone else i've got to make
it work for myself
so consequently i take that winning
formula anytime i'm in a stressful
situation
and i go immediately to everyone get out
of my way i'll do it myself
and that worked really well i think when
i started a company or i
in certain situations but in order to be
an effective leader
i had to do the next linguistic
abstraction that is choose freely
choose freely in any position to be the
type of leader that's required in that
moment
so i really became powerful at lou lemon
when i understood that
i could delegate i could ask for help
i could ask for opinions it didn't have
to be
all me and the more i find that i'm this
word busy
is more that tells me that i haven't
delegated or
trained and developed people to take
over jobs that i that i needed to do
time is precious in other words every
second of everyone's life is
critical and it's not up to me to waste
anybody's time and i really am
highly cognizant of tim if you only want
to go for 20 minutes i'm here for 20
minutes and i don't want to go
21 if you got something else to do you
know that's fine with me
so i i find that's probably where the
word complaining comes in
complaining is again a linguistic
abstraction to actually define
complaining and not waste people's time
and again
choose to take action which is another
linguistic abstraction as opposed to
complaining playing on the court not
living in the stands
so actually not observing life not
complaining about life but actually
getting into life and doing something
with it i could go on but that
i think you get this it's a good
sampling are are those
in your bathroom as
commandments or reminders of principles
for yourself
is it to refresh your memory of these
terms for communicating with
others what is the primary purpose of
having those in your bathroom
well to be authentic about my
inauthenticities
i'd say i'm so weak on integrity
i find myself complaining i put them up
because i'm so weak and i need to keep
reminding myself
about how much much my life has changed
even garnering 70 percent of what i say
other people should do 100 i guess it's
a little bit like that
smoker who's quit and then goes around
evangelizing how everyone should quit
smoking
or drinking or something do you know
what i mean it's uh
i'm kind of like a born-again
self-development person
so let's tie two pieces together which
we've covered in the last
20 minutes or so the importance of
authenticity
the value of being yourself
not what other people want you to be
and this is what we'll add sort of
reconciling that or combining that with
being a public-facing
ceo or leader of a company so you have
been
more than willing to share your thoughts
and opinions
and speak very openly in public in the
press
and it's not always been extremely well
received
do you have any regrets i'm not
trying to imply that you should i'm just
wondering do you wish you had done
anything
differently would you have done anything
differently or
was it really just who you are and
acting in integrity or authentically
was speaking really candidly and
publicly in the ways that you have over
the years
it's very tough to have an opinion
especially i think my area of expertise
in life is looking five years in the
future
and putting together what the world is
going to look like
especially in the realm of athletics and
apparel and that type of thing
but in order to be great at that you
have to see how all things in
society are changing now i have a big
failure in that
and the big failure is i didn't
understand in 213
because it was just the advent of social
media just that start of it
and it was a time when
i could probably say i was the first to
get taken down in what i'd call the
cancel
culture i didn't even really know what
had happened to me
could you for people who don't have any
of the backstory explain
what happened yeah sure so
i was going on bloomberg to talk about
this new concept that my wife and i had
around one minute meditation
so again the ability to choose in the
moment how my brain wanted to be
rather than having to do something
longer anyway it shifted into
blue lemon and it had a massive quality
issue
i wasn't the ceo at the time i was a
chairman living in australia actually
but that doesn't matter if i'm
responsible then i get to do something
about it
that's the way i look at it anyway she
pivoted and asked me about the quality
of the
the fabric and i went well i knew in my
mind that something was wrong
with the lululemon fabric or
something was going on because we were
getting returns we were getting
complaints like we'd never had before
and all i could really say at the time
was that some
of our pants don't work for some woman i
think i and anyway the interpretation of
vast majority of people that they heard
it from the point of view
oh i was judging woman in some sort of
way which
given that the business that i'd built
all about woman and all the women
inside of it nothing could be further
from the truth but i can understand
where their interpretation of that was
the reality of it is is that women were
buying two to three sizes too small in
order to
use it as compression like spanx and
like
any fabric or any material if you
stretch it too far
it's not going to work and kind of
that's kind of what was happening
but i didn't have that context at the
time so i was just trying to be as
truthful as i could
but it came across for if you again
listening through the lens of
oh you know you're judging me so i
didn't know women very well did i
as much as i say i was in a woman's
business and i was working with
thousands of women you know that i
didn't really get that this
kind of was occurring and maybe lou
lemon had just exploded from
being something that was very athletic
to something that was now
being uh bought by everybody in society
and so i made a mistake for sure
now what was interesting about it though
is just thought the
you know coming back to lou lemon and
the employees all supporting me they
understood where it's coming from but
the board of directors didn't
but nobody knew how the ends of the bell
curve that complained and complained
very loudly on social media
can sound so big nobody knew the size of
it really
what i say is that our customer was that
32 year old professional
woman single owner-owned condo athletic
very media savvy understood how all this
worked
and they weren't concerned with it but
it was really hard explaining that to
i think a world which was now moving
into a commodity media business
media went from like five or six big
newspapers to suddenly your digital
now you have infinite number of media
outlets and then the only way that you
can
attract people to your tv show
article or whatever is headlines and
then
sensationalism so i found that
people that said they were news outlets
were now becoming kind of national and
choir people magazine
sensationalism but they were saying they
were news outlets
which really does fool people who
don't have a context to what is news and
what isn't news and
we've gone so far in that direction of
this
media being a commodity product it's
like beer and cigarettes where it's all
done on marketing now
not really content and then the real
news is
i believe is what you're doing tim is
this
podcast or then let's be more specific
anything in the world that's working and
working really well now has eliminated
the middleman
you've eliminated the middleman so you
can come right to the source
rather than getting a headline or a 144
word whatever
it's helpful to hear i mean it's been
fascinating to see also just
in my experience the evolution or
de-evolution
the entropy of capturing reality and
anger and
rage and everything else in 144
characters or
less and it's a very
polarizing experience i think and also
seductive experience for
people to consume media now because as
you
indicated if you want to compete
effectively
for attention which is what these
companies are doing or their advertisers
are doing vis-a-vis their platforms like
facebook twitter etc
then shock sells right outrage sells
as does sex and vanity and these other
things of course greed but
it's a fun house mirror of sorts that is
adaptive
to each individual so it's kind of and i
don't want to
go too far but it's sort of dystopian in
its ability to
individualize without the individual
realizing
what is happening and of course this has
been discussed kind of
ad nauseam in uh documentaries like the
social
dilemma and so forth i wonder you
mentioned earlier this is going to be
a bit of a sideways step but i would
love to hear you describe what makes you
aside from extensive subject
matter expertise in your world right in
apparel and so on
how do you develop the ability to
really see what things might look like
in five years
because you seem to have done that over
and over and over again and i'm
curious if it's intuitive
if it's from a lot of analysis and
reading
if it's a combination if it's something
else what does it look like
to develop that skill well i probably
didn't know i had it
until i'd gone through a few iterations
but i think it really started off when i
was 12 or 13 years old and again
just i'm a reader i was a reader from
very very young age
and when i was reading and then i would
observe
i would formulate an idea in my mind
and about what the future was going to
be and then
i i think i just started noticing that
whatever i thought about actually was
coming true
and it's not like i'm a robert heinlein
or something you know some science
fiction writer
but maybe that was my area of expertise
and then because i was right so
often i probably just started
recognizing it that
it's something that i enjoyed doing and
then going okay now
let's kind of put my money where my
mouth is so to speak
i have these ideas if i lay down a
business to do that will the world
actually line up around what i'm
thinking
and it just so happened that that kept
occurring
now i'm 65 years old and i recognize i'm
not in the world of
knowing the minutia of social media
and e-comm and there's parts of that
i'm not living because i don't have to
live it it's not important to me because
of what
other things are more important so now i
feel i'm moving more to
understanding how companies are working
and how they become mediocre how they
become great
i'm really looking a lot about countries
and how
fascinated with how china is obviously
seems to me to be the next
empire of the world and how america is
becoming more like europe
over-regulated over-taxed moving further
to the left
and it's actually funny to me to look at
china now is the bastion of free
enterprise
yeah yeah i've been i've having lived in
china for a period of time
and studied it to universities and to
have seen
from visits there and i'm sure you've
spent quite a bit of time there as well
the change from bicycles
everywhere in beijing and people's
liberation
army green jackets to
the bikes disappearing to the audi
ferrari dealerships
to now i mean really what looks like
science fiction
in many of these mega cities i mean it
is almost
unfathomable how
rapidly things are evolving and
developing
in china so that's certainly going to be
an interesting x factor
from this point forward i'd love to ask
you
a couple of complete non-sequitur
questions about hiring
so i'm reading here just a note that i
have which says that
you've written about hiring people by
asking if they want families
i would love to hear you elaborate on
that yet in contrast
there are times in little black stretchy
pants when you share stories of rolling
down your window while sitting in your
car and offering someone a job you've
talked to for one minute
so what is it that you see in that
person that allows you
prompts you to make such a fast offer so
do you want families
and then the the fast job offer could
you elaborate on both of those
sure they probably overlap what i
noticed
notwithstanding there's always going to
be people that wouldn't want children
but through the landmark course i
noticed that almost 90 let's say
almost 80 90 percent of people had some
sort of issues with their parents
and really it came down to children not
forgiving their parents for the lousy
job their parents did of raising
them these are parents that loved their
children to death but it was just an
interpretation and a story
that the children would have i really
got were people that
really wanted children well one i think
it's the number two instinct after
survival
i think it's a great indication if you
want children you want a family
i really wanted to hire women who wanted
a family
and i was a little bit scared of those
that didn't
and then the part about me rolling down
the window it wasn't really like i'd met
the person for a minute
these were all people in my neighborhood
i was starting lou lemon
i'd watch them out running i'd have
watched them with their families
we were all young at the time and we all
had like three four
five year olds type of thing and i could
tell they were good people
because i've watched clothing all my
life i could tell they had
fashion sense or not or i'm gonna use
the word style i don't really like the
word
fashion but more like a style and so
when i kind of put the family and the
style together i went this is going to
be a person i'd like working for me
and because i didn't want anybody who
understood the wholesale clothing
business
that really i was open to hiring anybody
because there was nobody that knew the
vertical business
so it was like i got to take good people
train them in a new way of doing
business and that's what worked
so you didn't you didn't want to hire
anyone with kind of
legacy calcified thinking around
how this business should or could be
built correct
how did those hires turn out overall did
they tend to work out well i mean were
they for sales positions were they for
other positions
how did that experiment go the first
person i hired was deanne schweitzer
she was a single mother living in the
alley behind me with two kids
so i hired her to run our first store
and then she ended up being the head of
product for lou lemon
so probably ended up being the number
three or four person inside the company
i hired delaney to run the store after
her sister left and then delaney ended
up being the
number two person at lou lemon under the
ceo who
and i personally have always pushed for
delaney to be ceo of lou lemon but
i think the board of directors couldn't
see anyone but kind of an ivy league
type person kind of moving in there and
i
anyway i don't think they could have
been more wrong and i think that's been
proved out
and then probably the third person is
eric peterson who was
running marketing for electronic arts
here in vancouver
i knew that i had the olympics coming
and i wanted to grow the
marketing i wanted because i didn't have
any money to sponsor so
we uh we grilled the hell out of it and
he was uh he understood
long term word of mouth
community marketing and just again
giving
all three of these people really
understood giving without expectation of
return
looking for you know make a quality
product and in the long run just have
people talk about us
i think that's worked out rather well
over time
let me ask just a few more questions
and this one sometimes is extremely
difficult and unfruitful but i'll try it
anyway
sometimes it works out so we can we can
always fix it and post if it doesn't
if you could put a a message it could be
a
quote a word a question an image
anything
on metaphorically speaking a huge
billboard just to get a message or
anything out to
billions of people let's just imagine
they all understand
english what might you put on that
billboard
coming from my most gifted book which
would be catch
22 which is pulitzer prize winner from
the 1960s
about a bunch of pilots who flying over
northern italy and with an egotistical
kernel that kept making them do more
bombing missions till the time when they
realized that either they were going to
die next week or next month or two
months from now like
every minute was critical to the next
story of my
dad and always searching for the meaning
of life
and never finding it and if he did find
it then he'd be disappointed because he
had not no purpose in life other than
looking for it when i was 60 years old
i went to my dad and i went dad you know
if you had to give your 60 year old self
any advice what would it be and he went
away for a day
and he had the whole family around the
table the next day and he goes so i've
thought about it
and here's the advice i'd give my 60
year old self
do it now do it right now
so that's what i'd put on a billboard
uh what does that mean to you does it
mean is it principally just
valuing time and every second and if you
you really mean what you say
or value something truly that you're
going to just get after it
right away or does it have a different
different meaning for you
life is just so short and
what is the term that warner earhart has
there's no performance without action
so people think think think think and
they have an idea they have an idea
they'd like to do something
and it all comes down to action and
there's just not a moment to waste
there's not a second to waste in life
or you can choose to waste time which is
a highly
creative process so i don't want to like
say that that's not important
i'd say a lot of people have really
great ideas and maybe even they can see
the future and they
if they started their product or
whatever they're doing or their concept
right now
the first time they thought about it
then by the time they got their act
together the world would probably line
up and they'd be highly successful
can you wait that extra minute can you
wait that extra
month can you wait that extra two years
until everything's right well my kids
are a little bit better my wife loves me
a little bit
more i've got a little bit more money in
the bank i got more equity in my house i
can borrow
you know i i just don't think there's
time catch 22.
that is one of your most gifted books
why is that
there i am 18 years old reading it and
i've read it 17 times now so it's really
my bible in life
it was really a wake-up call again most
people don't get it until they're 43
like i talked about i got it when i was
18.
like here it's talking about all these
18 year olds and they're gonna die
and so they start to create well maybe
even like winning formulas because a
winning formula is what you do in a
survival situation so
they create different ways of surviving
with the short amount of time they have
left with them
so it's one of the great comedy books of
all time because you
have one of the characters dunbar that
decides that time goes too quickly when
life is fascinating
so he checks into a hospital and stares
at the ceiling
or we'll go in the back of a movie
theater and we'll stand in line go to
the front and then as soon as he gets
the front he'll go to the back again
and he refuses to talk to interesting
people because
time goes too quickly
so it's a series of mechanisms to make
life go slowly i've often wanted to be
in my physics 20 class for the rest of
my life just because i know i could live
forever
[Laughter]
what other books have you gifted often
to other people i know we've we've
mentioned a number of books throughout
this
episode are there any that that we
haven't mentioned yet
for me you know atlas shrugged was
massive for me you know to read that
again when i was 18
i mean i know nothing about u.s politics
and i could care less about the tea
party and all the way that people
because i had no context that it was a
philosophy i just thought it was a book
and you know when i read through the
book and
i really got about how to make a quality
product
how to treat people really well how not
to let
the naysayers say you can't do it or
that
if you do make your money that you know
give me part of that money because
why should you have it all type of thing
i didn't really get it until i was about
52 or 53 and i read the book again and i
recognized what an incredible
impact it had had on my life and i think
it falls part and parcel with that
good to great what is good and what is
great and did i possibly want to live a
life of being good at something
no i want to be great because on my
deathbed
why would i want to know what good look
like i want to know what grade looks
like
i've two very important questions
left the first is do you have
any favorite restaurants in
vancouver or the surrounding areas that
you can recommend
since as soon as i am vaccinated
which i'm waiting patiently for i am
going to be traveling
after my extremely strict quarantine do
you have any
any favorite spots or recommendations
for food
you know and unfortunately you know i
live in probably the nicest house in the
world
with the greatest view with a great wine
cabinet and a wife that
is second to none when it comes to
cuisine um so
you know we don't go out a lot but i'd
say so your house is the answer
that's where i need to go let me put it
this way when you're here you're invited
[Laughter]
where's tim i don't know i think i saw
him going down to the wine cellar
you uh-oh i'm not you know i have a my
favorite breakfast place is a place
called nelson the seagull
and they roast their own beans and they
make their own bread
and when you put that combination those
two smells together it's
phenomenal i know i'm not supposed to
eat any bread but the smell of that
bread's
great and you know it's one of these
places that
it's in a hundred year old building with
the big high ceilings
and they've put about five dollars into
tenant improvements
so you know what i mean they've just
gone and get gone to every
alley sale they could and bots chairs
and tables nothing mixes but the
quality of the product is second to none
it's such a stunning part of the world
and
there's such cultural richness there
there's such a bounty
of natural beauty and
excellent crabs among many many other
things
i wanted to make sure that we mention
something before closing and that
is that you've updated your
book this is the 2021 edition now of the
story of lululemon
and my understanding is you're making it
available
to download as epub or pdf for free on
your website
is that is that accurate and the the url
as i have it here for folks
is chipwilson.com forward slash book so
i want to make sure that uh
that we make note of that chip is there
anything else you would like to
say any ask request of the audience
closing comments complaints to the
editor that you'd like to file
with me uh or otherwise before we wrap
up
oh yeah yeah it maybe goes back to what
we're seeing but i'd
i'd like to make the request that people
reframe what the word
news means and i think
as i was saying that people have news
collapsed with sensationalism
negative news and as peter diamandis
says
you know our mindset is set by the
people we hang out with and the media we
consume
this is not just a plug for you but i
just can't say enough about
walking with audio and listening to
podcasts
and biographies books fiction it doesn't
matter the combination of these two
things is
so powerful keeping in great shape
and learning at the same time it's
fantastic so anyway
reframe the term news here here
uh i am on as as much of a low
information diet as possible these days
uh there's a lot of garbage calories out
there
you got to be careful do you have any
favorite audio books or audiobooks
you've really
enjoyed that that come to mind could be
biographies could be any category
oh yeah yeah you know i i actually um
of course you've had dan harris on 10
percent happier okay
i laughed all the way through that
learning about meditation
and i know you had guy razon i listened
to every one of them it doesn't matter
how many businesses i listen to
they're all different and they're all
fascinating and thanks for for
i like that little exchange of a podcast
you guys said it was good
um you know for people starting out the
e-myth
was really private for me you know being
able to put myself five years in the
future
train and develop people to take care of
the business so i could lead it
um michael gerber highly recommended um
another one
guns germs and steel i loved old peeled
surprise winning book about how the
world developed
and another one that's kind of an
updated one on that is dis united
nations
i really liked united nations just
united nations
i think my favorite author of all time
is john mccair you know did all the spy
novels and this
probably isn't relevant to anyone young
nowadays but
i love the british understatement
and his ability to tell a story and not
tell me anything
but it's all those small little
innuendos and the way the british talk
it
it's the very opposite from the american
marketing machine
if i can put it that way i like to learn
i like the way he makes me think and how
he uses words
you know i have english as a third
language so you know and that with no
first
two so i'm really i really
that's how i feel it's like kurt
vonnegut said paraphrasing here but he
said you know when i write i feel like
an armless legless man with a crayon in
his mouth that's
that's how i feel most days
and i could go on for a lot longer but
if you want me to but i
i think one of the most fun ones i
listened to lately was the magic strings
of frankie presto
and uh not familiar with it he brings in
musicians from all over the world
actually they give him approval to
talk about them and write them for him
to rate the story but
my audio was great and the potato
factory
middlesex i could go on and on goes on
and on
there is really just such a cornucopia
of
brain food available i'm finishing up
the overstory
right now which one of pulitzer and is
authored by richard
powers which is it's about trees and
each
vignette kind of ties together a person
or a
family line with a particular tree
or a particular old growth forest and
uh it's it's beautifully written very
dark at points which has been
challenging
but the pros and the storytelling is
just so
compelling that it's pulling me through
so that's another another fantastic book
and i'll plug it again the story of
lululemon updated
2021 can be found for free
at chipwilson.com forward slash book so
that's as good a starting place
as any and chip this has been so much
fun
i really enjoyed our conversation and i
appreciate you
making the time so thank you well thanks
for what you bring to the world
and i know it probably at some point
comes from a selfish point of view
because you're you get to do all these
great things
but uh isn't it nice when you can
combine the two
it is it is oh yeah this is i i have the
best job in the world i get to have
these types of conversations for a
so-called job so
until until they yank me out of here or
figure out that uh that i'm an imposter
i'll keep doing it
and uh so thank you again chip
and to everybody listening we will have
everything we discussed in the show
notes links to
everything at team dot blog forward
slash
podcast and until next time
do it do it right now get after
it folks
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little more soul of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird that i've somehow dug up
in the uh the world of the esoteric as i
do it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four hour
workweek.com that's 4hourworkweek.com
all spelled out and just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this podcast episode
is brought to you by helix
sleep sleep is super important to me in
the last few years
i've come to conclude it is the end-all
be-all that all good things
good mood good performance good
everything seem to stem
from good sleep so i've tried a lot to
optimize and i've tried
pills and potions all sorts of different
mattresses
you name it and the last few years i've
been sleeping on a helix
midnight flux mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you with helix
there's a specific mattress for each and
every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
in like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helixsleep.com
tim take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep
of your life they have a 10-year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk-free they'll even pick
it up from you if you don't love it
and now my dear listeners helix is
offering up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com tim
these are not cheap pillows either so
getting two for free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
tim that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com tim for up to 200
off so check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
tim this episode is brought to you by
four
sigmatic which is part of my morning
routine also part of my afternoon
routine routine saves me so there are
a number of ways that i use four
sigmatic in the mornings i regularly
start with their mushroom coffee instead
of regular coffee
and it doesn't taste like mushroom let
me explain this first of all
zero sugar zero calories half the
caffeine of regular
coffee it's easy on my stomach tastes
amazing and all you have to do
is add hot water i use travel packets
i've been to
probably a dozen countries with various
products from four sigmatic and their
mushroom coffee
is top of the list that's number one i
travel with it
i recommend it i give it to my employees
i give it to house guests
so if you're one of the sixty percent of
americans or more who drink coffee
daily consider switching it up this
stuff is amazing
that's part one that is the cognitive
enhancement side
easy on the system side energizing side
the next is actually their chaga tea
which tastes delicious it is
decaf completely decaf and some may
recognize
chaga it is nicknamed the king of the
mushrooms it is excellent for
immune system support so needless to say
i focused on that right now myself and
so i will often have that
in the afternoons they make all sorts of
different mushroom blends
if you are doing exercise as i am on a
daily basis to keep myself
sane cordyceps excellent for endurance
they have a whole slew of
options that you can check out every
single batch is third party lab tested
for heavy metals
allergens all the bad stuff to make sure
that what gets into your hands
is what you want to put in your mouth
and they always offer
a 100 money back guarantee so you can
try it risk free
why not i've worked out an exclusive
offer with four sigmatic on their
best-selling lions main coffee i
literally have a mug
full of it in front of me right now and
this is just for you my dear podcast
listeners receive up to 39 percent off i
don't know how we arrived at 39
but 39 off it's a lot they're best
selling lions main coffee bundles
to claim this deal you must go to
4sigmatic.com
tim this offer is only for you and is
not available
on their regular website go to four
sigmatic that's
f-o-u-r-s-i-g-m-a-t-i-c
dot com tim to get yourself some awesome
and delicious
mushroom coffee full discount is applied
at checkout